women are using social media to bring
awareness to a common yet rarely talked
about condition
ovarian cysts affect about 3 million
women each year in the united states
most go away on their own but in some
cases they can grow and lead to serious
complications
they might even rupture or cause
twisting of the ovary
in a tick-tock video raquel rodriguez
appears to be
very pregnant but reveals it's actually
an ovarian cyst look at that the video
has
been viewed more than a million times we
spoke to two women
who shared a similar experience i was
very surprised when i found out ovarian
cysts were
common in women 33 year lifestyle
blogger shantae burkett
posted her own ovarian cyst experience
to her more than
500 thousand social media followers she
wanted to see if
other women had similar stories the
response
overwhelming i received over
300 messages of women just sharing with
me their experience and
girls saying that they even had to go
through it at the age of 13
16 and it made me really aware of
what's going on burkett started to have
pelvic pain last december
by april she noticed her abdomen was
protruding
when i went to urgent care i went in
there basically like hey can i get a
scan on my stomach something definitely
is wrong
doctors found a 13-pound ovarian cyst
the size of a watermelon
burkette had no prior reproductive
medical issues
it was definitely like oh my goodness
like this is in me
how did it grow so big most sis resolve
on their own but about 8 percent of
women under 51
develop large cysts that need treatment
it took
four hours of surgery to remove it i
didn't know much about
ovarian cysts at all dory paulino's
nearly four
inch cyst was discovered during an
annual gynecological exam
my symptoms were so subtle and so mild
that for me it really it really just was
undetected
pauline assist was slowly growing for
about three and a half years before it
was removed
she says women need to be better
advocates for themselves
we know ourselves best so if there's
something that you feel that doesn't
seem quite right
don't just put it off don't dismiss it
nyu langone gynecologist dr tara
shirazian joins us now good morning dr
tara
none of this surprises you obviously
dory's actually one of your patients but
first of all explain to us what an
ovarian cyst is and how common is it
yeah ovarian cysts are extremely common
they're far more common than we even
have
numbers for because many women have
these cysts and they simply go away on
their own and so we often hear women
will ovulate they'll have a cyst
it will rupture it will go away you know
especially in reproductive age women
it's extremely extremely common
so when do you know when there's a
problem to the point where perhaps you
need to go into
a doctor and get surgery because we saw
you know the protruding stomach but at
what point what are some of the symptoms
women's pressure bloating definitely
growth of the abdomen
definitely visually seeing that your
abdomen is protruding
is a is a big warning sign you know you
don't want to watch your abdomen grow it
should not be growing over time that
needs to be assessed you need
imaging you need to be seen by a gyn
and of the rapidly growing masses we
either see
big ovarian cysts or fibroids so those
are the two big pelvic masses that are
relatively common well you may not be
surprised but i looked at that video and
my mouth fell open because i didn't know
they could get that big
i've had cysts but it was something that
you know you think you can hold in your
hand
when it gets that big that quickly is it
dangerous
yes so this is likely these women are
clearly surviving the one ladies singing
and dancing
right this is likely a mucinous cyst
mucin
mucinesis
get this large and they affect women
between 20 and 40 mostly
they can get quite big 80 or benign of
the mucinesis
17 are borderline so because they get so
big
they could have little foci that are
abnormal
and then the remaining three four
percent are cancer so
it's not a huge cancer risk right but
they could be borderline and clearly
they're creating lots of issues if you
have if you have one removed
are you more likely to have another or i
mean that's a good question so the
recurrence risk is roughly 15 to 20
yeah so if you have one ovarian cyst you
more are at more risk for another
um but i think the thing i found most
disturbing was
you definitely don't want to watch or
monitor that's what i didn't get tara
that you're watching this thing grow and
you know you're not pregnant
right how rapidly does it grow new
synthesis grow
quite rapidly over the course of a year
it can grow from like a few centimeters
too this is probably up to 25
even 30 centimeters in size does this
have an impact on fertility
it can because you may need to lose that
ovary right
and if there's any borderline area to it
or cancer there
you might even need to lose the other
ovaries so it is very concerning
do you think during the pandemic a lot
of us have put on weight do you think
women are thinking well it's really
nothing because i have
been eating more and i am getting a
little chubby i
have you've seen that so much right now
in the office
so many women coming in saying oh i
didn't think there was an issue i
thought i was just putting on the covid
15 or covet 12.
25. yes yes um and in fact
it's growing fibroids or it's growing
cysts
um so those are really those are the
things i see in treats so please come in
is it hard to detect i mean for for for
doctors even is it
do you miss them no it's pretty easy you
don't know because i'm wondering why
more people aren't talking about this
anything we can do to prevent it um
there's no
real way to prevent them i would just
say pay attention to your body
if you feel like you're bloating putting
on weight
regular bleeding sometimes even you know
make sure you come in
all right dr tara shirazi and thank you
so much for being with us this morning
thank you